a peaceful memorial service that ended
like this as mourners ran screaming
after a suspected drive-by shooting
outside a church in Houston six people
were injured Four Women and a
seven-year-old girl in a
life-threatening condition a 12 year
old's also been discharged from hospital
with a minor leg injury we heard like a
loud like a sound and then but I didn't
really take anything into it and then my
friend was like wait was I gunshot Queen
Macaulay was visiting her friend in
Flats next to the church when she heard
a gunshot and saw people running away we
literally saw like people are like kids
like running towards this direction so
we're like nah let's come back upstairs
um but then while we were downstairs we
could we literally saw like this black
Mercedes literally sped off the memorial
service was that of a mother and
daughter who died within a month of each
other last year twenty-year-old Sarah
Sanchez passed away from leukemia in
November it's not known whether the
victims attended the memorial service
but police were called here just before
half past one this afternoon after
reports that shots were fired from a
moving vehicle which was then driven
away from the scene what was supposed to
be a peaceful event ended in an act of
violence a metropolitan police statement
reads any shooting incidents
unacceptable but for multiple people
including two children to be injured in
a shooting in the middle of a Saturday
afternoon is shocking our thoughts are
with all the victims but in particular
with the seven-year-old girl who's in a
life-threatening condition and with her
family an investigation into this
Dreadful attack is already well underway
involving local officers and specialist
Detectives
as behind the police cord and forensic
officers assessed the scene and looked
for evidence an appeal for information
went out to the community to help bring
Justice to those responsible Adele
Robinson Sky News